Conan O'Brien there we go look at this
all right look we're playing we're
playing the best games you make it's
rude not to make eye contact I'm sorry
because it's rude your character in the
middle of a battle with someone when
another adult enters the room okay and
you're gaming you make icon okay
resume your game okay thank you when
we're playing airplane battle bay we're
going through ah some of the best games
of 2017 on the Google Play Store you've
never played a mobile game have you
would again like on your mobile device
like and of course I have I played a
mobile game board yeah oh sure okay
of course I have yes all right well some
stupid I love mobile games they keep me
from you know accepting the life in the
reality around me that's the best thing
about a mobile game there we go
ah you want to play battle bay yes okay
all right serious I love battle Bey
battle base awesome so here's how you
play so uh alright so basically who
wouldn't want to play battle I don't
know it's amazing all right let's see
how to the chat there's a paycheck
pillow pants shush OB Hey Osama shahe
Zoar and he mutts a wild Conan clone and
roast me say hi Patrick hi Patrick let
Conan play dumb ass okay okay
all right I just uh yeah yeah who's
Amish the sources let Conan play all
right you want to play uh there's this
game I love called flippin legend I
think I have a long lost son out there
yeah yeah call me we got to catch up man
all right you want to play uh there's a
game all right now let's place the
battle base yeah so basically this game
you're a ship you know actually it's get
out of here let's play a different game
this is one of my favorite games okay
this game is called flippin legend yes
all right
flippin legend so what I love my flippin
legend is it's very simple which will be
great for this dude and you're an archer
okay right and I and you're a very
acrobatic art yes okay and so yeah oh
yeah here we go all right so all you
need to do is you just tap either the
left or the right side and you're gonna
jump back and forth and you want to
avoid the bad guys
so you'll see
but don't back and forth and oh I mean
you want to kill the bad guys so you
guys to keep jumping how do I shoot an
arrow if I'm an archer you don't so go
you want to hit that guy you okay you
don't want to hit the pit all right wait
what wait what where why when do I shoot
well you can hit it you can hit this
thing to shoot an arrow but you'll jump
back it's kind of a okay what happened
died you died well I don't understand
question so hey listen yes I know you're
all gonna be snarky about my skills with
a Z but it wasn't clear to me you just
handed me this thing I coded me how I
play okay so basically there's a time
limit and it's it's counting down and so
you need to kill guys to keep getting
wet how do you kill them you you jump on
you just jump on there but you said I'm
an archer yeah but that's not how an
archer would function in the world he
doesn't jump he shoots an arrow but he's
like an AK is like an acrobatic card
trees like a ninja or plays never
shooters era well so you have once in a
while you can shoot an arrow whatever
you can only jump diagonal you know
chess yeah
okay it's not putting that what does
that have to do with Archie law I'm just
saying like in chess you know they're
dead don't call this an art for game
that's stupid
what are you okay it's like Jesus in
archery so not an archer game no all
right so we call it Archer but call it
hop-on crushed hop-on crush what's
trying to get her a hop-on crush alright
so you can only go diagonally so you
want to tap left and right right right
so to keep going and your time is
running out there at the top see so you
want to jump on those guys but sometimes
so sometimes it's not gonna line up oh
there you go see you hit your arrow
thing so you don't want to jump into the
pit you got to go fast you gotta go fast
like pow pow pow there you go pow pow
yep there you see this dump while you're
doing that with your hand well I'm
typing okay I'm just typing get you this
there you go oh yeah look at this yes
let's see how well you listened you got
this is the way you play chess chess is
a great analogy
I just put no thought into it you just
mash around what Barnabas you know I
mean chess in terms of like who thought
of this game this certain way this game
was not this game would not have passed
muster in 1979
I'm just saying that it's a you know
like that you can only move certain ways
there you go see you're killing all the
dudes yeah you're doing really good man
you're like wow you don't say good are
you doing let's use proper grammar
you're doing awesome is that can you say
awesome yeah you say awesome all the
time awesome so you're not a real adult
have you had a net do have you had an
adult relationship in your life no I
mean not with a person or like a video
game whatever all right no not with a
person but with a video game like I you
know there's you walk around the office
wearing ironic watches and saying
awesome sauce that's sure I got a watch
on today it has it dot in the line it's
great his watch in doesn't even tell
time because he's such a hipster yeah
but who needs to know what time it is
right that's true yeah well you know I'm
just saying you know time is a construct
anyway right it's not all just time
isn't real same room with you you don't
have to yet okay I'm just all right all
right you want to play oh and watching I
apologize the way he yells way too much
he thinks everything's awesome
everything is awesome great yeah
yesterday some mustard spilled on the
floor and he pointed out and said isn't
that awesome all right wait speaking of
mustard speaking of mustard how about a
cooking game yes a game where you cook
things this game's called cooking craze
it's one of the best to pick up and play
yeah if you don't like cooking yeah I
don't like cooking what better way to
spend your free time than playing a game
where you simulate the thing you don't
like to do have you ever watched you
what's your I make one thing alright
what do you make I make a tuna fish
sandwich with chopped onion and
mayonnaise and I put it on toast gross I
also can make new ramen noodles so I can
make those two things and I like to have
them together oh I like those two things
ramen noodles a bowl of ramen noodles
and a tuna fish sandwich with some onion
in it those are the only things that I
made all the time that I was a writer
sir Night Live
Simpsons all the shows I've worked on
when all those years that I was alone
working on my craft yeah I call it a
craft that's how I worked on that
that's what fueled you that was your
creative fuel in those years those
eighteen years if you're calling in if
you wonder why I'm dressed like a 1930s
newsman I don't know we have a lot of
work today and I was really busy so I
came right from a workout because you
don't just get this body
I wore my kooky hat and who's what why
the ladies are laughing my body remark
Pansear is asking to pregnant you
present pregnant them con and pregnant
me I don't know if that pregnant sought
a verb is conan a real comedian no
really not really
i love it though the you're asking me as
you seem genuinely confused no I'm not a
real comedian those are you know what
something bad when people can make hot
pockets we have you have you had a hot
pocket what's your position on hot
pockets movie my position addition
that's an efficient way to to eat
something bad quickly what do you want
do you want to do you want to do a quick
cooking game quickly before you go I
know you have a show to do they're very
very quick yeah let's do the cooking
game all right we're gonna do all right
we're gonna do this is gonna make donuts
are you a donut fan and I love donuts I
try not to eat them sure because it's
all sugar and carbs yes nothing in there
and every time you eat a donut you
shorten your life this is a true medical
fact by one year that's been proven if
you have like eight doughnuts you're
gonna be dead and in at least a year if
you're in your 40s all right so let's
make some donuts here we go so here we
go we're trying to please that's a
stereotypical view of us yeah he's
clearly Italian you're making a pizza
pie so what do i doing alright so
there's gonna be customers that are
gonna come up and they're gonna have
what they want that's not what they're
asking for is like a sprinkle chocolate
doughnut it's our job to cook the donuts
and keep the kid on okay okay keep the
kitchen weak so you want to test the
donuts keep tapping the donuts and then
when they're done they're to put them
over just half the donut they're done
they're burning tap the donut - yup put
it over there alright now I got to put
some chocolate sauce on there you'll hit
some coconut sprinkles for that guy
coconut sprinkles for that guy you could
just tap the coconut tap the coconut
sprinkles yeah all right now give that
guy that doughnut press the press which
guy he doesn't want that just have to
don't it'll go to the right guy oh it
automatically goes to the right guy what
skill is that but you got to keep
tapping the donuts to keep them keep the
kitchen movie okay okay yeah keep okay
yep all right
the big donut pick tap the pink donut
there I got it alright yeah give the guy
the milkshake there alright your Donuts
a burnin all right give that now you
want to put the pink sauce on the other
donut by up this guy is doing weight
kind of trying to find you know dubs are
fooled until you got to do the pink
sauce and the donuts there you go yes
yes there we go there we go alright now
that you know chocolate can I say
something yes there's not enough people
working here in a kind of business look
at this jerk burn something burn somethi
he knows I burned something he knows I
burned something alright see that oh you
tap it twice to toss it away
see look look at that look at this see
you look game there we go see you just
got it's all about donut management you
know you just gotta gotta keep it go and
keep they keep the kitchen move in there
we go it's gay akshay one of maybe six
reasons why the American Empire is in
decline that's right there we got the
coconut sprinkles look at this see it's
just like it's all about tapping it's
all about you just got to keep that baby
going I think I could probably run a
donut shop right there's an elf for
giving the donut at the elf 3 dish combo
look at that
you're there's aunt you're an empty
person inside there's nothing inside you
that's an empty shell this is true uh
alright you know it's not a good game
when I'm actually being distracted by a
bottle of water it's sitting on the
floor I saw this and I was looking at it
like huh that bottle doesn't have I
wonder what kind of bottled water it is
it looks like it hasn't had no one had
it yet it seems to be room temperature
that's what I'm thinking about what you
make it and I'm killing it over here
look at this thing the snowman guy got
this stuff so this is for children yeah
yeah I mean yeah it's there we go
I'm a winner look at that you yes it
just said I'm a winner you're just your
life was just affirmed that's by an
offensive stereotype exactly I'm a
winner I thank you by the way for the
jacket the the Christmas gift that we
all got thank you for that jacket did
you pick that I picked that I did
actually save me a bunch of options for
the Christmas jacket and I saw that
bomber with a hood yeah and I liked it
yeah I said there's only one
problem it doesn't say Conan and when
people walk around with and that's the
kind of a hole I am when I give a gift
it has my name stamp when I give my you
know my mother uh a bouquet of flowers
it spells out watch Conan on TBS yeah
see there it is right there you can be
that's a nice bomber jacket right there
you can't really see you'd have to have
someone model it yeah
the Beth model did earlier there okay
got it got it cool that zip around the
bicep there just got these cool pockets
yeah you can keep all your cool stuff
that's right it's pretty great um how
long have you been doing the honey games
you playing uh we're playing all these
games okay it's amazing yeah we and it's
amazing what does that mean it's amazing
that there's this many awesome games on
the Google Play Store everybody gonna
notice me I have Tito's tattoos for
Heisenberg do you want to see you want
to see one other game no okay all right
okay all right well thank you Happy
Happy Holidays to the check us happy
holidays everybody why do you talk to me
like I'm an old man to nursing home well
you're wearing that hat like an old man
be holidays are you gonna say it grab me
get you mush mush
hey someone said they don't like my hat
you're crazy
look at all the stick I can do with this
hat I'm sorry could I get a bank loan
drunks I've got a cab it's 1948 look at
this this guy ever even know that guy
does the hip-hop kind of it was not
hip-hop okay again this I'll see you
guys later bye everybody who's doing
this and thank you for your mostly
positive comments and you know okay so
[Laughter]